what was the longest one to complete for
the Shady robots that you remember
because he spent on a few of them you
spent quite a long time
[Music]
which is also inspiring when you take so
long in a project yeah I think um kind
of in the more like fun Whimsical
Department rather than shitty robots I
built recently
um this music box so like a small music
box that kind of has a barrel with
little spikes and it plays the song but
I did a large version of that that pops
a sheet of bubble wrap and then like
plays tones into a pan flute so yeah you
can actually program it to play
different songs
that one kicked my butt in so many
creative ways that it was such a pain I
think that is probably the like
weird funny project that's taken me the
longest and like the biggest engineering
effort where's the all sound coming from
so if you it all came from me realizing
that if you pop bubble wrap and you pop
it right in front of the opening of a
pamphlet or like one of the pipes you
can have it play different tones
so that's what it does so I built this
music instrument off of that okay if
it's okay can you describe some
something like how it works some of the
the technical details here yeah so
basically I mean one of the
so I worked with
um as of a year and a half back I hired
an engineer stew so we were
collaborating on it
um but a big issue that we had was
feeding in the bubble wrap sheet and
like making sure that it feeds them
straight and doesn't get skewed because
you need to make like the popping feet
which is where you program this Barrel
to pop different bubbles need to be so
perfectly aligned on the bubble of the
bubble wrap for it to pop in the right
location so there's a feeder for the
bubble wrap that's a challenge and then
you have to have a barrel with the
little baby feet on it yeah that pops
the ball why is it so exciting that
Barrel was a pain as well I had to get a
like this rotary setup for my CNC and
yeah it was it was a lot of work
um but that was really fun and it's just
like
this is probably my
favorite
privilege of my job is that I can
go down any Rabbit Hole I think find
interesting did you have a lot of
Joy from popping the
yeah the bubbles a lot of stuff through
the end like I got to spend I think I
spent a week trying to figure out the
best material to pop bubble wrap with
because if you have two if you kind of
put them to to through uh or through if
you put a sheet of bubble wrap through
two rigid tubes the air kind of just
escapes from one side of the bubble into
the other so what I realized was that if
you have a squishy material like kind of
a yoga mat material in between it it
actually it prevents that and Pops it a
lot more reliably by like increasing the
pop reliability was a huge effort as
well you have to pop a squishy thing
with another squishy because you don't
need a lot of force yeah like you just
need it to not the air to not be able to
escape anywhere wow but then also we had
there was different qualities of bubble
wrap where there was a lot of
transference between different bubbles
so instead of the bubble popping it
would just seep the air into a
neighboring bubble and that like
membrane would kind of so you know I I
just like getting to spend weeks on
weeks of just studying bubble wrap did
you ever think about like publishing a
academic work on Bubble Wrap no wouldn't
that be epic because nobody's done this
I bet you nobody's done squishing it
squishing material on Squishy versus
squishy
for popping I bet somebody has but you
know I I always I thought I was going to
go into Academia like I was such an
ambitious student I loved school I I
actually applied to MIT but then I
pulled out because I was like no I don't
want to do it
um but now I realize it's really good
that I didn't because I'm too much of a
spass too much of the spaz now I'm
distracted I'm thinking there must be
papers about when you have two bubbles
yeah you need to know the physics of two
bubble when when you have two bubbles
colliding
one will pop first
and there has to be good models of that
but that's very that has to do with
chemistry and whatever the uh the
material the ball was made from but then
no there's materials in here there's got
somebody must understand bubble wrap
deeply
like deeply so I'm just going to take a
quick restroom break because uh Lex is
on his own train now and I'm just gonna
leave you guys yeah
I really don't need to go to the
restroom okay
I'm gonna insert like a two hour uh
instructional here with like a
Blackboard right it's the skill of
skillister it's I
throw you any topic and you could just
go on about it I don't know if I have
that skill
okay
um Bubble on Bubble an interaction go